[Music]
like to go to the bathroom on in the tub
what it was an emergency it's not even
cool man especially when we have a whole
other bathroom downstairs I think I
could make it to that one it's 20 paces
away well it would have been like 16
pieces too many trust me and then you
would anatomy for making a mess on the
floor okay so what do you want me to do
sure you want to do this well why not I
mean there's a camera right there
why are you building yourself taking a
bath
think that's any of your business
actually I think maybe it is can you at
least cover up what like cover up dude
your Johnson it's like right in like
field of view and I'm trying to do
tackle here Johnson to you I'm not
entirely sure why you would care if it
was in your line of view and people
thinking that we're like gay or
something you said that kind of thing a
lot of them starting I think maybe
you're a homophobe
no no I'm not homophobe you're the
homophobe homophobe you're the qualified
yep I'm just straight I mean I'm sure
the right situation presented itself oh
you know what the right person okay you
would go gay who would you go gay for
probably like a movie star or a movie
character right who in the movies if you
were given the chance would you give on
Washington you said that kind of fast no
no almost like you've thought about it
before I've certainly never thought
about going there for Denzel Washington
make sure or George Clooney dude what
about you homophobe
dude I'm not on the photo pay forward
the movies no like really get straight
have to be somebody like Gandalf
probably get Liam Neeson no no no what
much more incredible than Lee
mr. incredible no dude if I'm gonna go
gay for a movie character it's not gonna
be a cartoon it's gonna be like somebody
magical and powerful like Gandalf I
think I would go gay for Gandalf yeah I
mean he's wise he's funny he's got
superpowers I mean what's not to like
he's like a thousand years old though
dude age ain't nothing but a number
besides that guy travels by Eagle man
when the story calls for it I didn't
laugh from Life of Pi
Richard Parker that's Tiger yeah man you
tear your face off Richard Baca all
right that's it I'm coming in you
should've thought about before
now I'm naked but you
[Music]